les gens qui sont masqués
nous sommes poussés par un traumatisme vous êtes obsédé
par la justice parce que si une injustice
qu'ils ont subie ergo le masque il cache la
douleur je porte les masques pour me protéger
de la douleur
il y avait un calvaire impliqué de tirer la
nuit dernière tu dois  donne-moi le discours
maintenant quel est le discours je devrais l'appeler
respire où Oregon sait qu'il y
a un gars dans mon coffre
délicieux mets-le dans la nacelle tu sais
pourquoi tu es ici
alors a frappé ma porte mets-moi dans le
coffre notre  [ __ ] de voiture oh c'est correct
maintenant ce que mon avocat ouais nous n'avons pas à
faire ça les terroristes
pourquoi recommenceraient-ils cette merde
peut-être qu'il y avait quelque chose qu'il ne voulait pas
Pam ils avaient une mission John j'ai juste
oublié que la volière a  nos noms et
adresses
[Musique]
J'étais comme Angela s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît nous allons
votre vaste et insidieuse conspiration d'une
torsion de l'os des phares
qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est
le seul moyen de vous montrer la vérité dont
vous avez besoin d'aide pour empêcher la septième cavalerie
de faire ce que ces  les [ __ ] essaient
de déclencher une guerre
[Musique]
eh bien on dirait que vous avez les choses sous
contrôle ici
costume cool Merci
[Musique]
Oh dit visite fan Lucy